[Musica]
bene Siamo su questo pianeta da circa 5
milioni di anni e per il 999% della
nostra storia siamo stati Cacciatori e
raccoglitori poi si può dire che ieri
l'altro cioè 9000 anni fa con la
cosiddetta rivoluzione
neolitica è cominciato quello che chiamo
il disastro della nostra
evoluzione Abbiamo cominciato a
coltivare ciò che
raccoglievamo e abbiamo cominciato ad
allevare ciò che cacciavo di per sé
questo non sarebbe una cattiva notizia
se non che anche quello che qualcuno
oggi Chiama l'antropocene è nato
lì da lì sono nate tutte le disgrazie
della nostra evoluzione O almeno per
come l'abbiamo presa noi è nato il
sedentarismo è nato l'accumulo dei
beni con l'accumulo dei beni sono nate
le guerre per procacciarsi questi beni è
nata la società stratificata e cioè
discriminatoria al di là di come la
chiamiamo soprattutto c'è stata una
svolta evolutiva di cui poco si parla
nel
999% della nostra vita
precedente nel Paleolitico noi non
conoscevamo non eravamo in grado di
cogliere il nesso tra l'atto sessuale e
il parto e la nascita erano due eventi
troppo distanti tra di loro Abbiamo
cominciato a capire come
funzionava osservando gli animali in
cattività con il
Neolitico Questo vuol dire che per circa
5 milioni di anni cioè fino a ieri
l'altro Noi abbiamo ignorato il concetto
di
paternità e facendo così abbiamo
ignorato anche il concetto di
maternità in quanto le due cose vivono
in
simbiosi quella che noi chiamiamo vita
nel Paleolitico prima di questo ieri
l'altro era qualcosa che non veniva
generato non veniva percepito come
generato da qualcosa altro ma si
autogenera in una specie di arborescenti
in una specie di
miracolo La nostra percezione
miracolistico
era ciò in cui
vivevamo
l'unica
potenzialità che erroneamente potremmo
chiamare
soprannaturale Ma è una distinzione che
non esisteva all'epoca era quella data
alla femminilità che si
autogenera in una procreazione
arborescente e permanente È per questo
che l'unica
deità concepita in quei periodi fu
quella della grande dea o come qualcuno
la Chiama Dea Madre non era madre perché
non c'erano
padri la poesia credo che appartenga a
questi C milioni di anni
e per
poesia Intendo quella che poteva essere
Allora l'arte della parola che era
un'arte riservata a quelli che noi oggi
Chiamiamo gli sciamani i professionisti
della parola o per meglio dire alle
origini le
sciamane eravamo sciamani che danzavano
cantavano siamo diventati scrittori che
inconsciamente le sillabe della metrica
della
poesia moderna per moderna Intendo
quella tra 9000 anni fa a
oggi mimano inconsapevolmente questo
grande canto arcaico che ancora
sopravvive proprio in certe comunità
Native che ancora si può osservare come
all'origine di quella che noi chiamiamo
la poesia
quando 3 milioni di anni fa siamo scesi
dagli alberi come australopitechi e
abbiamo incominciato a usare la parola
abbiamo fatto uno sgarro evolutivo
erratico abbiamo riciclato degli organi
che si servivano per deglutire masticare
respirare creando la
parola non credo per una necessità
comunicativa non all'origine ma
per non doverci guardare dal
mondo Abbiamo riciclato questi organi in
un vero e proprio
miracolo per potere raccontare i sogni
per potere raccontare le
storie per potere viaggiare Quando
stavamo
fermi per poter sognare in maniera
diversa quello che gli sciamani fanno
ancora
oggi le parole sono la cosa più effimera
che esiste
perché sono percepite una volta che
muoiono anche adesso io sto parlando
l'ultima parola che avete sentito e
percepito mia è morta se n'è già andata
mentre parlavo e questa peculiarità di
essere effimere si sposa con la
peculiarità di essere gli artefatti più
duraturi che l'uomo che omo Sapiens
abbia
creato le parole riciclano se stesse e
dentro ciascuna delle parole che usiamo
anche le più banali si nascondono strati
di storia e di
preistoria si potrebbe parlare di tante
parole magiche i nomi degli insetti nei
dialetti i nomi dei fenomeni atmosferici
ma anche parole più banali la più banale
che mi viene in mente è
computer quando noi abbiamo un computer
la parola
computer che designa l'oggetto che tutti
noi ben conosciamo è un riciclaggio di
una parola inglese Anzi un vero e
proprio
della parola
computer ma la parola computer nasce dal
latino
computare Perché i primi computer erano
dei calcolatori e computare significa
contare ma la parola computare nasce da
putare un verbo già diffuso nel
Neolitico quando la potatura degli
alberi questo significava potare putare
potare un albero ci ha consentito la
lessicalizzazione
di una infinita serie di attività
reputare computare disputare tutte
parole
concezioni
eventi nati in quel periodo quando
appunto la potatura degli alberi era
diventata una delle
attività rispetto alla quale si potevano
lessicalizzazione
ha dietro di sé qualcos'altro C'è una
radice indoeuropea che è Pot
put il nome della dea di cui parlavo
prima antico indana devi la Maha devi
uno dei nomi dei testi antichi in
sanscrito è
potna che è forse connessa anche l'idea
di potere Ma non come lo intendiamo dopo
il
Neolitico quindi nella parola computer
questi estani oggetti che utilizziamo
amente con tutte le loro appendici la
parola computer per quanto le parole
siano la cosa più effimera che abbiamo e
muoiano di continuo anche adesso mentre
parlo e noi le percepiamo quando sono
morte la parola computer vuol dire che
ha dietro di sé almeno 25.000 anni di
storia perché viene da quella
radice qui non si tratta di fare
dell'algebra da linguisti si tratta di
capire che ogni parola funziona in
questa maniera
sicché quando dico che fummo sciamani e
diventavamo poeti è perché noi in quei 3
milioni di anni da quei 3 milioni di
anni in poi quando siamo scesi dagli
alberi come pitechi avevamo parole che
erano foglie erano rami erano tempeste
erano fiumi
erano
arcobaleni è stato lì il miracolo primo
della parola quello di cui parla
nella fondamentale poesia che è stata
retta all'inizio di questo incontro sul
miracolo solo che whitman essendo post
Neolitico parla di
miracolo mentre nel Paleolitico questo
sarebbe stata la normalità o meglio
nemmeno la normalità non c'era un
soprannaturale e un naturale ed è lì che
la poesia
interviene la poesia interviene come
atto di
dissidenza Perché quando noi non il
mondo lo abbiamo incominciato a fare
proprio per non guardarci dal mondo
potevamo passare da un luogo infausto o
pericoloso o anche semplicemente
guardare un cumulo di
pietraie senza doverci guardare da esse
perché
nominando potevamo
interiorizzarlo grande Tabù sono parole
che non si possono pronunciare nemmeno
oggi che fanno
paura solo che questa
tendenza Anzi questa possibilità
originaria della nominazione del mondo
di Non doversi guardare dalle cose ha in
generato quella che per noi di Homo
Sapiens è un'abitudine assai pervicace
Cioè ha generato l'abitudine quindi le
parole Si opacizzano e anche i referenti
delle parole si
opacizzano per dico che la poesia È un
atto di dissidenza perché il poeta Da
sempre è colui che ci restituisce lo
stupore delle cose quando le nominiamo
per la prima
volta è un atto di dissidenza perché è
anti
evolutivo la poesia è anti evolutiva
anche se Noi fummo poeti all'inizio
prima ancora di saper parlare e ciascuno
di noi lo è prima ancora di saper
parlare la lingua dei bambini se
studiate in in quest'ottica ci rivela
tante cose della nostra lingua
originaria e dello stupore e
dell'incantesimo di nominare il mondo
ricordarlo e
raccontarlo come però i grandi ghiacciai
non si sono mai estinti Ma hanno
forgiato con le morene e le loro potenti
epiche portentose epiche hanno forgiato
dei paesaggi tipo quelli collinari
montuosi che anche qui su nel nostro
Appennino esistono allo stesso maniera
alla stessa maniera quei secoli e quei
millenni e quei milioni di anni non si
sono estinti Naturalmente perché la
rivoluzione neolitica è appena
cominciata e ne vediamo i danni Oggi
potremmo declinarli secondo diverse
specie quando appunto anche le religioni
cambiarono non ci fu più la religione
della dea ma le religioni patriarcali
quando si scoprì la fecondità maschile
Ecco Jupiter il dio padre che la terra
qualcosa di impossibile prima Ecco il
dio pastore delle società pastorizze del
quarto
millennio e anche qui le parole però
come vere
malandrine mantengono traccia di ciò che
fu un tempo perché la parola dio Deus è
collegata a una radice indoeuropea che è
la radice te Che significa allattare
Quindi in realtà ricicla una parola che
significa l'
allattatrice de
Deus in uzione in questo progetto
evolutivo di Homo Sapiens è in realtà
riconoscente la grande idea di ciò che
essa fu ne prende Addirittura una
caratteristica che non può
avere in questo atto di dissidenza della
poesia la rende peculiare la rende quasi
difficile ma ogni vero grande poeta come
i versi di whitman che abbiamo letto Ed
è certamente uno dei grandi poeti ci
parla proprio di questo si risveglia le
percezioni a quel tempo di cui parlavo
la
poesia non era solo fiumi lampi
tempeste non era solo le moltitudini del
mondo che vivevano nelle parole era
anche
cura la parola curava Ecco un'altra
caratteristica per cui abbiamo
incominciato a parlare il canto curava e
io credo che la poesia oggi possa ancora
farlo e particolarmente che possa grazie
ai poeti o ad alcuni poeti curare il
mondo in declino a cui assistiamo e mai
come oggi c'è bisogno di una poesia
dissidente proprio oggi che i
dispositivi di soggiogamento
statali o non quelli nati col
Neolitico si sormontano da tanti punti
di vista una via possibile che salverà
il mondo è quella delle parole sempre
perché è una via individuale è una via
di
consapevolezza è una via è un miracolo
che si compie dentro ciascuno di noi
vorrei concludere
questa chiacchierata allora eseguendoli
un canto sciamanico della tradizione
inuit del Canada
settentrionale un canto tradizionale che
veniva in parte viene ancora eseguito
dalle sciamane e dagli
sciamani al termine dei se di notte
artica quando appunto tutto si risveglia
e tutto è percepito come un miracolo noi
lo percepiamo meno perché come scrive
whitman il sole sorge ogni giorno lì è
percepito come miracolo quello che per
noi è normale in questo
Colgo una possibilità del canto
sciamanico e della poesia di risvegliare
le nostre
percezioni quindi eseguendo questo canto
ho in mente Più che altro
noi non le tradizioni inuit ho in mente
quello che la poesia può essere oggi
quando raccogli un'eredità
di radici che non si sono mai
[Musica]
perdute
K
i
magen
[Musica]
Jag Jag
heilen
in
[Musica]
Mat KO
Mat
[Musica]
h
[Applauso]
im
[Musica]
[Applauso]
ti
[Musica]
per 5 milioni di anni nessun poeta è mai
vissuto lontano dalle stelle soltanto la
poesia e soltanto la dissidenza
salveranno il
[Musica]
[Applauso]
mondo